et bienvenue dans vue de Russie la
chronique hebdomadaire qui analyse la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur fond
de guerre en Ukraine avec Elena
wolochine comme chaque semaine bonsoir
Elena bonsoir Stéphanie à la une en
Russie l'attaque présumée hier dans la
matinée de ce que les médias officiels
russes présentent comme un groupe de
saboteurs Ukrainiens oui dans la matinée
d'hier beaucoup d'informations
contradictoires ont circulé à ce sujet
en l'absence de journaliste indépendant
sur place il est toujours très difficile
de comprendre réellement ce qui s'est
passé les médias officiels Russes eux
sont tenus de ne citer que la version
officielle des faits et la voici cette
version telle qu'elle a été donc dictée
hier à ces médias par le FSB et par
Vladimir Poutine lui-même écouté
un attentat terroriste dans la région de
briank c'est ainsi que le président
Poutine a qualifié l'attaque des
combattants Ukrainiens les nazis ont
pénétré aujourd'hui dans le village
loubécanier ils se sont dispersés une
première brigade s'est planquée près
d'un arrêt de bus et attiré sur un
véhicule civil le conducteur est mort
sur place un petit garçon de 11 ans est
à l'hôpital baignant dans son sang il a
sorti deux fillettes du véhicule un
autre groupe de nazis a largué un engin
explosif depuis un drone sur le village
sous Chagny un immeuble d'habitation a
pris feu
voilà donc selon cette version dans un
village une attaque armée de
nazi-ukrainien contre un véhicule civil
plus tard les chaînes de télévision en
russe évoqueront un deuxième mort les
détails de cette histoire sont jusqu'à
présent très peu clair notamment comment
cet enfant sorti de cette voiture que
vous allez voir à l'écran a été blessé
alors qu'il était blessé par balle
aurait pu parcourir plusieurs kilomètres
en sauvant deux autres fillettes de ce
véhicule être ensuite déposé par une
voiture chez des inconnus chez une
connaissance de la famille lui faire le
récit des faits et seulement après cela
être admis dans un hôpital c'est comme
ça que les chaînes de télévision russe
ont raconté cette histoire en tout cas
dans le récit elles insistent bien sur
le fait qu'il s'agissait soi-disant de
nationalistes ou de nazis
ukrainien selon les moments du récit
c'est un terme générique nationaliste
nazi employé par la propagande russe
pour qualifier tous les combattants
Ukrainiens non seulement depuis le début
de la guerre à grande échelle en 2022
mais même depuis le début de la guerre
du don-basse en 2014 autre élément
narratif répété à la boucle depuis hier
par les officiels et les médias russes
la balle extraite du corps du petit
garçon blessé serait américaine écoutée
après une opération qui a duré plusieurs
heures nous avons sorti une balle de
fabrication étrangères de la cavité
pleurale gauche c'est un miracle que le
cœur et les poumons n'est pas été touché
il a été opéré la balle a été extrait
c'est une balle
une balle c'est une arme de fabrication
américaine voilà
une certaine hésitation Elena le but de
ce narratif dicté par les officiels
russes c'est comme toujours d'accuser
les Occidentaux l'OTAN les Américains de
faire la guerre à la Russie par le biais
de l'Ukraine oui exactement et alors que
l'enquête ne fait officiellement que
commencer hier Vladimir Poutine lui
avait déjà établi les responsabilités
écoutez
ce sont des gens qui se sont donnés pour
but de nous priver de notre mémoire
historique de nous priver de notre
histoire de nos traditions de notre
langue
soyez très vite c'est isica c'est de la
violence c'est un véritable crime commis
par les néonazis et leur maître il n'y
parviendront pas nous les achèverons
Vladimir selon Vladimir Poutine les
ukrainiens et les Occidentaux et nous
les achèverons cela fait penser bien sûr
à une autre phrase célèbre du président
russe oui pour ceux qui se souviennent
le 24 septembre 1999 Vladimir Poutine
déclare nous poursuivrons les
terroristes partout si on les attrape
dans les toilettes on les butera dans
les toilettes on était alors en pleine
seconde guerre de Tchétchénie Vladimir
Poutine doit justifier aux yeux des
Russes les bombardements massifs sur
groszny la capitale tchétchène il fait
alors évidemment référence au terroriste
tchétchène qui aurait perpétré une série
d'attentats à la veille de cette guerre
cette similitude de langage n'est sans
doute pas le fruit du hasard hier au
même moment où Vladimir Poutine parle de
terroristes pour désigner les prédendus
les prétendus saboteurs Ukrainiens les
chaînes de télévision russe elles se
mettent justement à comparer leur action
à présumer avec des événements qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir en disant que
c'est la même chose regardez
il faut bien comprendre que les méthodes
employées aujourd'hui par les
terroristes Ukrainiens ne sont pas
nouvelles un scénario presque identique
d'attaque terroriste contre un village
pacifique contre ces infrastructures
civiles avec une prise d'otages c'est
déroulée en 95 à bouillonnesques à
l'époque plus de 100 personnes sont
mortes dans l'attentat terroriste
qu'avec une prise d'otage dans un
hôpital en 95 un an plus tard la taxe
surprise
voilà ce que l'Ukraine s'est donné pour
méthode désormais entrer avec des armes
dans un village Pacifique fusillé et les
habitants du parti c'est là la patte
bien reconnaissable des terroristes le
premier à avoir combien un tel crime
monter russe et bah ça y est en 95 ils
ont tué 129 personnes en anglais c'est
500 il n'hésitait pas à prendre en otage
des femmes enceintes et des bébés
un discours qui fait écho dans la
mémoire des Russes ces reportages sont
destinés avant tout à présenter les
Ukrainiens comme des tchétchen à
l'époque comme des terroristes et
justifier la guerre de Poutine en
Ukraine comme à l'époque la propagande
justifiait la guerre en Tchétchénie oui
sauf qu'avec tout cela la propagande
russe n'a toujours pas mentionné jusqu'à
présent l'une des informations
principales dans ce dossier qu'elle
traite à savoir le fait que les attaques
d'hier elles ont été revendiquées et non
pas par des Ukrainiens mais par des
Russes plus précisément par les membres
d'un bataillon nommé le corps bénévole
russe c'est un bataillon officiellement
intégré dans les forces armées
ukrainiennes hier il a publié deux
vidéos sur sa chaîne télégram regardez
mes amis c'est fait le corps bénévole
russe affranchit la frontière de la
Russie voici la preuve derrière moi
nous faisons pas la guerre aussi villes
nous ne tuons pas des gens désarmés leur
est venue pour les citoyens
russordinaires de comprendre qu'ils ne
sont pas des esclaves rebellez-vous
battez-vous
nous sommes venus ici pour vous libérer
nous vous appelons à prendre les armes
et à combattre le régime sanguinaire de
Poutine gloire au corps bénévoles russes
mort au tirant du Kremlin
parle de libérer les Russes du régime de
Poutine mais ce ne sont pas des enfants
de chœur non le premier homme sur la
première vidéo c'est un certain Dennis
niquitine ironie de l'histoire alors que
la propagande russe voit comme on le
sait des néonazis Ukrainiens partout
celui-ci est bel et bien un néonazi mais
un néonazi russe passé côté ukrainien
instigateur de mouvement de hooligans
qui ont notamment aussi sévi en Europe
organisateur 2 matchs de MMA Dennis
Nikitine c'était aussi un proche d'un
autre néonazi russe très célèbre maxime
Martin kevitch dit caissac il est mort
en 2020 dans une prison de haute
sécurité en Russie où il purgeait
plusieurs peines de prison pour
assassinat et violence aggravée vous le
voyez en ce moment à l'écran et Dennis
nikitting donc ici à déménager en
Ukraine en 2017 pour combattre aux côtés
des Ukrainiens une journaliste
ukrainienne Yanina Sokolova l'a
interrogé à la veille de son incursion
planifiée sur le territoire russe pour
mener son action elle l'a interrogé sur
ses motivations écouter ce qui lui a
confié
je suis un néonazirus que ce soit pour
les Ukrainiens les européens ou les
Russes je suis mauvais pour tous
la j'estime mettre un patriote de mon
pays je n'ai pas honte j'étais je suis
et je resterai un nationalisme russe
estime et cardinal dans mon système de
valeurs le nationalisme russe est devenu
taré il a pris une toute autre direction
que je ne le voudrais moi je vois une
Russie pour les Russes ce n'est pas du
tout ce qui est en train d'être bâti sur
le territoire de la fédération de Russie
et ce n'est pas le modèle à l'export que
Vladimir Poutine est en train d'essayer
d'imposer au territoire en Ukraine
et Léna mais contre le régime de Poutine
parce qu'il trouve que le président
russe ne sert pas la cause des ultras
nationalistes des néonazis russes oui
effectivement alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que jusqu'au milieu des années
2010 les mouvements néo-nazis avaient le
vent en poupe en Russie les attaques
contre les personnes non slave pas
seulement les immigrés mais aussi les
Russes d'autres ethnies que cela à
Moscou et dans d'autres grandes villes
russes étaient très fréquentes elles
étaient extrêmement violentes et
largement impunies mais depuis 2014
depuis le début donc de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine et de nouvelles lois passées à
ce moment-là sur l'extrémisme sur fond
de durcissement des répressions le vent
a changé c'est donc cette mise sous
coupe réglée des mouvements néonazis que
dénoncent Denis niquitines et quant au
média ukrainien il relay eux aussi donc
les versions des responsables
officielles Ukrainiens qui eux disent
que l'Ukraine n'a rien à voir avec cette
attaque oui hier sur son compte Twitter
le conseiller du président
ukrainien mikhaïlo podologue parlé d'une
provocation délibérée de la part de la
Russie sans préciser comment c'était
déroulé cette provocation et dans le
même temps il affirmait que le mouvement
des partisans prenait de l'ampleur en
Russie la chaîne de télévision
ukrainiente elle interrogé un
responsable du renseignement militaire
ukrainien écouté
les médias pro Kremlin se sont mis à
propager des versions contradictoires de
ce qui s'est produit à la mi-journée une
vidéo est apparue ou des combattants qui
se disent appartenir au corps bénévoles
russes on revendiqué les faits TSN a
demandé un commentaire à la direction
générale du renseignement de l'Ukraine
là-bas on affirme que cet incident
témoigne d'une confrontation au sein
même de la Fédération de Russie et que
le corps bénévole russe agit comme une
entité politique au sein de son pays
c'est un conflit intérieur russe et les
citoyens russes qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec la dictature de Poutine ont décidé
de lutter de cette manière et d'appeler
d'autres à la lutte
de dire que ce bataillon de rue c'est
intégré à l'armée régulière ukrainienne
oui parce que tout comme les Russes ne
veulent pas dire que des Russes
combattent contre Vladimir Poutine les
Ukrainiens ne veulent pas dire que des
néo-nazies russes combattent pour eux au
final bien que récupérer par la
propagande de part et d'autre et bien
cette action de ce bataillon elle semble
finalement ne servir que ses propres
intérêts alors il y en a en tout cas qui
qui en a un pardon qui en profite pour
rappeler à Vladimir Poutine qu'une
attaque sur le sol russe contre des
citoyens à civils russes et bien ça
devrait appeler une réaction un peu plus
musclée qu'elle ne l'est actuellement
c'est bien sûr yefghani Prigogine le
chef du groupe paraméditeur de
mercenaires Wagner qu'on commence à
connaître maintenant parce qu'il est
largement sorti de l'ombre depuis peu et
il est de plus en plus actif dans sa
critique contre le commandement russe
écoutez
des lignes rouges on dirait qu'on a plus
de peinture rouge à la place c'est de la
peinture brune et à la place des lignes
du gribouillis
ceux qui en font
voilà donc
on ne comprend pas vraiment ce qu'il dit
au premier abord mais c'est quand même
le seul en Russie qui ose critiquer en
personne le commandant un chef des
armées Vladimir Poutine et ceux qui lui
dit donc là en substance c'est qu'un
sabotage un tel sabotage c'est
inadmissible en Russie et que si
Vladimir Poutine ne le punit pas et bien
c'est lui qui s'en chargera merci Elena
et vue de Russie ça sera à nouveau la
semaine prochaine vendredi prochain
merci encore